electric buses are a bad idea they might
have their niche applications but
generally we shouldn't be moving in this
direction not with the alternatives
available to us now what makes me say
that to understand the issue with
electric buses let's take a look at
atmospheric rail it was a real novelty
originating from as far back as 1799
according to the wiki page anyway the
idea was that locomotives are bulky and
heavy they're a pain to maintain they
need coal water sand and so on so why
not have one big quote-unquote
locomotive next to their tracks which
propels strains on the network while
stationary in practice this meant big
boiler houses that pumped steam into a
big pipe between the rails to which
carriages were connected with a piston
as the steam flew through the pipe it
propelled the train forward the early
projects all failed however due to the
technological shortcomings at the time
the biggest issue was the sealing of the
pipes they used leather flaps which
froze during winter and dried out during
summer rendering the whole system
unusable in both cases turns out steam
locomotives are just more practical
since you don't have to pay attention to
kilometers of piping if you want to run
a train now normally this would be the
point where i would say and so the
atmospheric railway concept was
abandoned in favor of better solutions
but it kind of wasn't not since we've
invented electric traction today's
catenaries are essentially a form of the
atmospheric railway only instead of a
steam plant pumping steam into a pipe we
have an electric plant pumping
electricity into a wire this way we
don't have to generate the electricity
on the tracks i.e diesel locomotives
this might be a surprise to some but
it's not the diesel locomotive's engine
that moves it forward the engine is
spinning a generator which then powers
the electric motors which then move the
train with catenaries you can get rid of
the engine which means more efficiency
power and capacity alright so how does
all of this tie into electric buses
before we get into it a quick word from
today's sponsor atlas vpn offering you
the best vpn deal on the market for just
139 per month with a 30-day money-back
guarantee it's a high-speed service more
than suitable for both gaming and
streaming in addition atlas is more than
just a simple vpn it also blocks all the
malicious links ads and trackers and
notifies you when someone is trying to
steal your data it also helps you find
the best deals during online shopping
including subscription services such as
netflix or spotify right now atlas vpn
is running a huge discount it means you
can get a 3 year subscription for just
1.39 a month with a 30 day money back
guarantee and with that single
subscription atlas vpn will protect all
your devices of course this offer will
not last forever but you can take
advantage of it right now by clicking
the link in the description that's a
three-year subscription for just 1.39
cents per month with a 30-day money-back
guarantee protect your data and privacy
and get access to all the content that
has been previously locked away from you
by region blocks thank you for checking
out atlas vpn ads like this help support
what i do and now back to the program so
how do the atmospheric rail diesel
engines and catenaries tie into electric
buses well electric buses do the same
thing as cutting array based systems and
the atmospheric rail except in reverse
electric buses are basically
trolleybuses with a local power source
of course this does make them flexible
i.e they can go everywhere without an
overhead wire but here's the thing where
will they actually go you see electric
buses are mainly used inside cities and
city bus lines have this attribute of
not changing their routes i.e the bus
will run on the same route 99.9999
of the time so if we know the exact path
of the bus in advance why not just put
up some wires above that route that way
we don't have to mess with the heavy
batteries weighing down the bus not to
mention the enormous safety hazard you
know how electric cars tend to basically
burn to ash when the battery catches
fire electric buses can do the same
except with a battery multiple times the
size speaking of batteries their
construction and disposal are very
polluting not to mention the occasion of
slave labor involved in the mining of
the necessary rare earth metals a
further problem is that electric buses
aren't a good option where public
transit is needed the most i.e
developing countries electric buses are
much more expensive as it turns out
costing up to twice as much as diesel
buses so a country or a city with
limited funds can either buy say 500
electric buses or 1 000 diesel buses now
electric buses are generally cheaper to
operate so they would save money on the
long run but during that time you only
have 50 capacity since you're earning
500 buses instead of a thousand that
means potentially tens of thousands of
cars stay on the road hundreds of
thousands of people will not have access
to good public transit and so on
especially in developing countries this
can cause losses much greater than any
cost savings by electric buses since
potentially hundreds of thousands of
people won't have access to
high-capacity affordable public transit
this will very likely set them back
economically which means a major tax
loss for the local authorities you know
someone living in a shanty town could
have finally taken a job in another area
of the city since they could have
actually commuted there with the bus
they would have made a salary which they
would have spent at businesses boosting
the local economy and increasing tax
revenue but if we get half as many buses
we won't be able to provide affordable
transit for a lot of people meaning
they'll stay at home on welfare at best
or contribute to an increasing crime
rate at worst i can guarantee you that
the combined cost of additional welfare
and policing and the missing tax revenue
will be a much greater amount that any
savings electric buses might bring so if
the priority is cost and capacity diesel
buses win hands down otherwise as i
mentioned before we can just put up some
wires and run a trolleybus service
instead and to all the nimbies out there
trollipis fires aren't big or ugly or
visually polluting here's an image of
dohan street in budapest where
trolleybuses run as you can see the
wires are barely visible so trolleybuses
are all well and good as an alternative
but what if the wires break or if
there's an accident and they need to
take a detour i have good news we've
already solved this problem in the form
of autonomous trolleybuses this means
the truly bus has a small battery or
diesel generator inside that allows it
to run without a wire usually between 10
and 30 kilometers this way they can
bypass accident sites or reach areas
without overhead wires thus solving the
flexibility issue now some people might
say okay so it works inside cities
that's nice but we can't possibly put up
all these wires between cities to which
i say yes we can they're called trains
and if the distance is too short for
trains to make sense then trams or if
the distance is too short for trains but
too long for trams then tram trains so
no matter how we flip it electric buses
just don't make a whole lot of sense
inside cities it's better to use diesel
or trolleybuses and outside cities it's
better to have rail of course as i
mentioned in the beginning there can be
some niche applications for electric
buses but they are just that so the
whole concept of electric buses as we
applied today is pretty dumb and i
actually have the same opinion about
battery powered
it's just a way for our decision makers
to not invest into rail i.e proper
electrification instead they can and
will use the money to build more
highways for example and why wouldn't
they most of them only use their cars
and will die before climate change
really hits us and that will be our
problem not theirs in summary aside from
some niche applications electric buses
are not the solution to anything they're
mostly just a way for cities to quickly
check the environmentally friendly box
and then go back to their unsustainable
car centric practices without the
necessary systemic investments into
public transit and better urban planning
or in the best case scenario they're
just cute little pr stunts oh look we
get some electric buses now 1.27
of our entire bus fleet is electric
powered climate change btf btfo'd anyway
thank you for watching and don't forget
to like and subscribe and i also have a
patreon if you think this content is
worth your money and i'll be seeing you
next time